This story of voyeurism, innocent voyeurism, starts off simply enough. Pete was supposed to meet a friend when she got off from work. He arrived two hours early.
这个关于偷窥的故事，一种无辜的偷窥，开始得再简单不过了。皮特本该在他朋友下班时去接她。他早到了两个小时。
So to kill two hours, I was just wandering around in the alleys, digging through the dumpsters around there, seeing what there was. And as much as I like to look through dumpsters, there's not a whole lot that I'm excited about finding. I'm not real big on eating food out of dumpsters. So the one thing that really gets me excited is finding other people's mail. I love reading other people's mail. I actively look for it on the streets and in people's garbages, in dumpsters, at post office.
为了打发这两个小时，我就在小巷里闲逛，翻翻附近的垃圾箱，看看有什么东西。虽然我喜欢翻垃圾箱，但并没有什么让我特别兴奋的发现。我不太热衷于从垃圾箱里找食物吃。所以唯一让我真正兴奋的是找到别人的信件。我喜欢读别人的信。我会在街上、人们的垃圾里、垃圾箱里和邮局主动寻找这些信件。
On this particular day, Pete found a big bag of letters, maybe 100 pieces of mail, written over a year and a half. He's excited. It seemed like hours of reading.
就在那一天，皮特发现了一大袋信件，大约有100封，写于一年半的时间里。他很兴奋。这看起来足够读上几个小时了。
They were in no chronological order, so I just had to open the first one that I could grab. And read one after another that way, which was kind of confusing at first because I jumped right into the middle of what appeared to be a relationship between a woman and a man. But I slowly put it together as a puzzle.
它们没有任何时间顺序，所以我只能随手打开第一封我能拿到的。然后就这样一封接一封地读，起初有点让人困惑，因为我直接跳进了一个看起来是一个女人和一个男人之间的关系中间。但我慢慢地像拼图一样把它们拼凑起来。
Here's the picture that emerged as he put this puzzle together. The woman lived in another country. The guy lived in the United States. And while visiting her country, staying in a hotel there, he slept with this woman once. She wanted to see him again, idealized him, wanted to come visit him. But none of these trips ever seemed to happen. Pete only had the letters that she had written, her side of the story. But sometimes in her letters, she repeated things that he said.
当他把这些拼图拼凑在一起时，呈现出的画面是这样的：女人住在另一个国家，男人住在美利坚合众国。在访问她所在的国家期间，他住在那里的一家酒店里，和这个女人睡过一次。她想再见到他，对他产生了好感，想要来看他。但这些行程似乎从未成行。皮特只有她写的信，也就是她那一方面的故事。但有时在她的信中，她会重复他所说的话。
And over the course of the correspondence, all sorts of things happened. This woman went to jail, and then lied about it to the guy, and then finally admitted the whole thing. She lied about a daughter of hers. She actually said that a daughter of hers had died. And then finally admitted, no, no, I was just lying about that. And over the course of these letters, this woman slowly puts her life in order. She goes to school, she gets a new job, often taking advice from the guy.
在通信的过程中，发生了各种各样的事情。这个女人进了监狱，然后对那个男人撒了谎，最后承认了整件事。她关于自己的一个女儿撒了谎。她其实说她的一个女儿已经去世了。然后最后承认，不，不，我只是在撒谎。在这些信件的过程中，这个女人慢慢地整理好了自己的生活。她去上学，找了一份新工作，经常听取那个男人的建议。
I think it is just she never had somebody to really lean on and to seek advice from or just to tell her problems to, or at least nobody who was stable. And so he says it's going to be platonic. And she says oh, that's fine, that's fine. But when you read between the lines, she just wants to see him and maybe once they reunited then the sparks will fly again.
我想只是因为她从未有过可以真正依靠和寻求建议的人，或者只是向其倾诉烦恼的人，至少没有一个稳定的人。所以他说这将是柏拉图式的。她说哦，那很好，那很好。但当你细读字里行间，她只是想见他，也许一旦他们重逢，火花就会再次迸发。
As he read, Pete started to feel protective of this woman. The guy seemed to be sending mixed messages. The guy, to him, seemed like a total jerk, really. He was always making her think that he might want to see her, but then he would always quash any plans that they had to actually get together. And this is the thing about reading other people's mail, as you read you cannot help but read between the lines. Anybody with any heart, any half sense of empathy fills in the details that are missing. You're thrown into this world that's part fiction writer and part detective.
阅读时，皮特开始对这个女人产生保护欲。那个男人似乎在传达矛盾的信息。对他来说，那个男人看起来简直是个混蛋。他总是让她觉得他可能想见她，但随后他又总是会扼杀他们实际聚在一起的任何计划。这就是读别人信件的特点，当你阅读时，你忍不住会细读字里行间。任何有心的人，任何有一点同理心的人，都会填补缺失的细节。你被扔进了这个世界，既像小说家又像侦探。
I had to keep in mind that he had just thrown these letters out apparently. And so no matter how important she may say that he is to her, at some point he puts it behind him. These letters now are in the dumpster.
我必须记住，他显然只是把这些信扔掉了。所以无论她可能说他对自己有多重要，在某个时候他还是把他抛在了脑后。这些信现在都在垃圾箱里。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it is This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you documentary stories, original fiction, radio essays, anything we can think of on that theme. Today's program, Other People's Mail, stories of people reading stuff they're not supposed to see in the first place, and how it moves their hearts, and what happens after that.
大家好，来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来纪录片故事、原创小说、广播随笔，以及任何我们能想到的关于该主题的内容。今天的节目是《别人的信》，讲述人们阅读他们本不该看到的东西，以及它如何打动他们的心，以及之后发生的事情。
Act One of our program today, Dead Letters. Richard Lyons walks through a car junkyard and finds in the crumpled up wrecks letters and notes of the people who once lived in these cars. Act Two, Thief. A college girl steals other people's mail. Mona Simpson reads an excerpt from her short story. Act Three, Saviors. A visit to the only post office employees who are allowed to actually read your mail. These are the people who deal with letters whose addresses are unreadable or incorrect or nonexistent. They open up the mail to try to get it to where it's supposed to go. Act Four, Voyeurs, in which our own Sarah Vowell picks a fight with me. Stay with us.
今天节目的第一幕，《死信》。理查德·里昂斯走进一个汽车垃圾场，在破损的残骸中发现了曾经住在这辆车里的人们的信件和笔记。第二幕，《小偷》。一个大学生偷了别人的信。莫娜·辛普森朗读了她短篇小说的一个片段。第三幕，《救星》。参观唯一允许真正阅读你的信件的邮局员工。这些人处理的是地址无法辨认、错误或不存在的信件。他们打开邮件，试图将其送达目的地。第四幕，《偷窥者》，其中我们自己的莎拉·沃威尔找我吵了一架。请继续收听。
Act One, Dead Letters. Well, Richard Lyons is in the band Negativland, which is known for using a lot of found sound in their recordings. And a couple years ago he put together-- he xeroxed just a couple copies of it for a few friends. And it was made of these objects he had found, letters and notes. It's really this incredible document. When you open to any page, what you see is, on the right side there's a photo of some smashed up, demolished car. And on the left, there's a letter or a shopping list or some note found inside that totalled car. He agreed to tell the story here. All the names and certain identifying details have been changed.
第一幕，《死信》。好吧，理查德·里昂斯是Negativland乐队的成员，该乐队以在录音中使用大量现成的声音而闻名。几年前，他整理了一些东西——他只为几个朋友复印了几份。它是由他发现的这些物体、信件和笔记组成的。这确实是一份令人难以置信的文件。当你打开任何一页时，你看到的是，右边是一张被撞毁、拆毁的汽车的照片。左边是一封信或购物清单，或是在那辆报废的车里发现的一张便条。他同意在这里讲述这个故事。所有的名字和某些身份细节都已更改。
The inspiration for my project came about in the spring of 1994 while visiting a local automobile wrecking establishment in Contra Costa County, California. While searching for a Bendix spring for Negativland's company mascot, a 1976 Mercury Monarch Ghia, I made a shocking discovery. I stumbled upon a metallic root beer 1971 Dodge Demon that I'd previously owned and meticulously maintained until selling it two years earlier.
我的项目的灵感来自于1994年春天，当时我访问了加利福尼亚州康特拉科斯塔县的一家当地汽车拆解厂。在为Negativland的乐队吉祥物，一辆1976年的水星Monarch Ghia寻找本迪克斯弹簧时，我有一个惊人的发现。我偶然发现了一辆金属根汁汽水色的1971年道奇恶魔，我之前曾拥有并精心维护过它，直到两年前将其卖掉。
To my horror, the car had been broadsided with great force and the occupants had been neatly extracted with the jaws of life through a perfect cut over the edge of the roof line. Upon further inspection, it became obvious that the car had not only been wrecked, but trashed over a period of time beforehand. Curiosity led me to search its interior for clues on what methods of torture could have brought my once beautiful car bomb to this endscape.
令我惊恐的是，这辆车遭到了巨大的侧面撞击，车内人员被用“生命之钳”通过车顶边缘的一个完美切口整齐地取出。经过进一步检查，很明显，这辆车不仅被撞毁，而且在此之前早已被糟蹋了一段时间。好奇心驱使我搜查它的内部，寻找是什么样的折磨手段才让这辆曾经美丽的汽车炸弹落得如此下场。
And what I found was fascinating. The melted plastic seats and orange carpet were littered with an assortment of paper scraps documenting the life of a 17-year-old single mother and her tumultuous relationship with an abusive 38-year-old boyfriend. The car smelled of sewage water and empty Pepsi containers attracted bees. But I continued to collect and collate everything I could find, love notes, hate letters, personal records, receipts, photographs.
而我所发现的东西令人着迷。融化的塑料座椅和橙色的地毯上散落着各种各样的纸屑，记录了一个17岁单身母亲和她与一个虐待狂38岁男友之间动荡的关系。车里散发着污水味，空的百事可乐容器引来了蜜蜂。但我继续收集和整理我能找到的一切，情书、仇恨信、个人记录、收据、照片。
Dearest Jack, if you love me as much as you say you do, will you please spend time with me and the baby? You said you'd take care of me and I don't know what I should do to make you keep your promise. I love you, Jack, and I hope you'll forgive me for not being able do some things good enough. But I want you to at least be here for all of us. And I hope you can see my point. Will you please come back? Love, Erica.
亲爱的杰克，如果你像你说的那样爱我，请你花点时间陪陪我和孩子好吗？你说过你会照顾我，我不知道我该做些什么才能让你信守承诺。我爱你，杰克，我希望你能原谅我，因为我有些事情做得不够好。但我希望你至少能为了我们所有人而在这里。我希望你能明白我的意思。你会回来吗？爱你的，艾丽卡。
Several days passed before I fully realized the extraordinary effect this experience had on me. I couldn't help wondering if she'd been killed or badly injured, and what about her infant son? Was she even in the car? Perhaps her drunken beau, in a fit of uncontrollable rage, had taken the Demon on its fateful joy ride.
几天后，我才充分意识到这次经历对我产生的巨大影响。我禁不住想，她是死了还是受了重伤，那她的婴儿儿子呢？她甚至在车里吗？也许她那醉酒的男友在一阵无法控制的愤怒中，带着这辆恶魔号进行了那次致命的兜风。
If Jack doesn't want to be with me or Max, he can do whatever he wants. I don't care if he wants to do crank and everything else to get high. I can find someone who will be better for me and I know will be around at least sometimes and care about me and us both.
如果杰克不想和我或马克斯在一起，他想做什么都随他。我不在乎他是否想通过吸食毒品和做其他事情来寻求快感。我可以找到一个对我更好的人，我知道他至少有时会在身边，关心我和我们俩。
I recalled observing similar remains in other discarded vehicles. And upon further consideration, I picked up my camera and left to see what else was out there. The older cars were the most interesting-- unpaid parking tickets, failure to appear notices, unopened mail from collection agencies, lottery receipts, losing game cards from fast food restaurants. Then there were the letters. I found one letter in a 1977 Buick Regal, whose roof had been completely torn off and the body was twisted in half.
我回想起在其他废弃车辆中观察到的类似遗骸。经过进一步考虑，我拿起相机，出去看看还有什么。老式汽车最有趣——未缴纳的停车罚单、出庭通知、来自讨债公司的未开封邮件、彩票收据、快餐店的输球卡。然后是信件。我在一辆1977年的别克Regal中发现了一封信，它的车顶被完全撕掉，车身扭曲成了两半。
My love, Joe. Hi. How are you doing? I hope I can get through this hell hole. I love you with all my heart and miss you very, very bad. I got four months, that's 102 days here in jail. Joe, if you love me like you say, will you wait for me, please? Whatever you do, don't leave me. Come see me on Saturday. Visiting hours, 2:00 to 4:00 PM.
我的爱人，乔。嗨。你怎么样？希望我能熬过这个地狱。我全心全意地爱你，非常非常想念你。我在监狱里待了四个月，也就是102天。乔，如果你像你说的那样爱我，你会等我吗，求你了？无论你做什么，都不要离开我。周六来看我。探视时间，下午2点到4点。
I heard you were here to see me, but I never seen you. What happened to you? Well, my love of my life, I won't be here too long. I'm hurt because I never seen you in court with me. Calvin said you was here. I'm trying to get a three-way phone so I can call you. If you can find someone with a three-way phone, please get the phone number and let me know. Well, Joe, this is just a little letter to let you know what's going on. When I get more paper, I'll write you more, longer letters. I love you, Joe, with all my heart. Miss you real bad. Forever your love, Debbie.
我听说你来见过我，但我从没见过你。你怎么了？好吧，我一生的挚爱，我不会在这里待太久。我很受伤，因为我从未在法庭上见过你。卡尔文说你来过。我正试图弄到一个三方通话电话，这样我就可以给你打电话了。如果你能找到一个有三方通话电话的人，请拿到电话号码并告诉我。好吧，乔，这只是写给你的一个小信，让你知道发生了什么。等我有更多的纸，我会给你写更长、更多的信。我全心全意地爱你，乔。非常想念你。永远爱你的，黛比。
Joe, Virginia said you don't want to talk to me so we are through with each other and I am getting abortion. I don't want your baby, so leave me alone. Love, Debbie.
乔，弗吉尼亚说你不想和我说话，所以我们结束了，我打算去堕胎。我不想要你的孩子，所以离我远点。爱你的，黛比。
I photographed every car I searched and compiled the information in the form of a xeroxed book, transcribing the text exactly as it was written and positioning it next to the photo. I pulled a list from a crushed 1987 Volkswagen Fox entitled, What I Need. Couch, love seat, chair, coffee table, dinner table, TV, radio.
我拍摄了我搜查过的每一辆车，并以影印书的形式整理了这些信息，将文本完全按照书写的方式抄录下来，并将其放置在照片旁边。我从一辆被压扁的1987年大众福克斯里找到了一份清单，标题是《我需要的》。沙发、双人沙发、椅子、咖啡桌、餐桌、电视、收音机。
I found a writing assignment by a local community college student in a totalled Chevy van. Apparently, he hadn't learned his lesson. James D., English 122, November 22, 1993. One, a car accident two years ago taught me the dangers of drinking and driving. A car accident, it's bad. Two, Who? Him and his buddies. What? Drove drunk. When? 11:30 PM, Easter eve. Where? Route 11. Why? Young, stupid, high on beer. Three, Yes, he answers all questions. Four, Monte Carlo Super Sport, night before Easter, Route 11. Five, Yes, it all leads up to driving drunk.
我在一辆报废的雪佛兰货车里发现了一份当地社区大学学生的写作作业。显然，他没有吸取教训。詹姆斯·D，英语122，1993年11月22日。一，两年前的一场车祸教会了我酒后驾车的危险。一场车祸，很糟糕。二，谁？他和他的哥们。什么？酒后驾车。什么时候？复活节前夜，晚上11:30。在哪里？11号公路。为什么？年轻，愚蠢，喝啤酒喝高了。三，是的，他回答了所有问题。四，蒙特卡洛超级运动，复活节前夜，11号公路。五，是的，这一切都导致了酒后驾车。
I came upon a 1979 Cadillac Fleetwood Brougham, whose front end was so mangled that the engine was pushed through the firewall and up into the windshield. In it was another student paper, only this one was probably passed quietly in class.
我偶然发现了一辆1979年的凯迪拉克Fleetwood Brougham，它的前端被撞得面目全非，引擎被推过防火墙一直撞进挡风玻璃里。里面是另一份学生的作业，只是这份可能是上课时偷偷传阅的。
Natalie baby, so how are you sweets? You look so cute. Say, next time you talk to Marge, tell her I hope she feels better. Why is she so sick? Well, how's your baby? I can tell it's going to be so cute just because you look so cute. Happy 25-week anniversary. Yeah.
娜塔莉宝贝，你好吗，甜心？你看上去真可爱。说真的，下次你和玛吉说话时，告诉她我希望她感觉好些。为什么她病得这么厉害？好吧，你的孩子怎么样？我敢说它一定会很可爱，就因为你看上去那么可爱。25周纪念日快乐。耶。
So what you been up to? Since you forgot to write me, I wrote you. Cool, huh? Well babe, pretty neat note, huh? Not. I gotta go, but you better write back to me. See ya, Audrey. Tell baby I said hi.
那么你最近在忙什么？因为你忘了写信给我，所以我写了。很酷，对吧？好吧宝贝，很棒的纸条，对吧？才怪。我得走了，但你最好写回信给我。回见，奥黛丽。告诉宝贝我问好。
I found a letter in a 1978 Toyota Celica Liftback. The car was so badly crushed on the left side that the driver's door took up the entire front seat.
我在一辆1978年的丰田Celica掀背车里发现了一封信。这辆车左侧被压得太严重，以至于驾驶座的门占据了整个前排座椅。
Bill. Hello, how are you? I am OK. A week ago, I got burned on my right hand. We had a grease fire in the kitchen and I received second degree burns on my hand. We were going to make tacos. We left for three seconds and it went up in flames. That's why my writing is not that good. It's really not as bad as it sounds.
比尔。你好，你好吗？我还好。一周前，我的右手烫伤了。我们在厨房里发生了油脂火灾，我的手受到了二度烧伤。我们本来打算做塔可。我们离开三秒钟，它就燃起了火焰。这就是为什么我的字写得不太好。其实并没有听起来那么糟糕。
I can't remember if I told you, but I had a miscarriage July 8. But it's almost been a month and I'm doing a lot better. I was in the hospital six hours. I thought I had three IRs, but my ex-roommate, Michelle, said I had five. I'm kind of glad I lost it since I wasn't in love with the guy. I told him I was pregnant and he really seemed like he didn't care. That's OK. I didn't love the guy. He was hooked on crack and the baby probably would have come out mental.
我不记得我有没有告诉你，但我7月8日流产了。但已经快一个月了，我感觉好多了。我在医院待了六个小时。我以为我有三个IR，但我以前的室友米歇尔说我有五个。我有点庆幸我失去了它，因为我并不爱那个男人。我告诉他我怀孕了，他看起来好像根本不在乎。没关系。我不爱那个男人。他吸食快克，孩子生出来可能也会是智障。
Here's a picture off-guard. I don't have any more pimples. And I am not that white. My hair is getting a little longer and better shaped. Well, I'm going to let you go for now. My hand's starting to hurt. Write back, please. I'll enjoy it. After you send the money order, don't write because I'll be on my way. I'll call and let you know as soon as I get it. Love always, Ginger Joy.
这是一张我不留神时的照片。我没有更多的粉刺了。而且我也没有那么苍白。我的头发变长了一点，形状也更好了。好吧，我暂时要让你走了。我的手开始疼了。请回信。我会很开心的。在你寄出汇票后，不要写信，因为我就要上路了。我一收到就会打电话通知你。永远爱你的，姜味快乐。
In about a month's time, I'd collected more than enough documents to complete my book. But the act of gathering them had become an obsession and it was difficult to know when to quit. I finally stopped myself after an eerie discovery in a car that had been demolished beyond recognition. It must have belonged to a member of the church choir, and strangely, it was the only thing in the car-- a single photocopy of a hymn by Dion de Marbelle, "When They Ring The Golden Bells."
大约一个月的时间里，我收集了足够多的文件来完成我的书。但收集它们的过程已经变成了一种痴迷，很难知道什么时候该停下来。最后，在一辆被损毁到无法辨认的汽车里有一个令人毛骨悚然的发现，我才停了下来。它一定属于教堂唱诗班的一名成员，奇怪的是，它是车里唯一的东西——一张狄翁·德·马贝尔的赞美诗《当他们敲响金钟时》的单张复印件。
"When our days shall know their number, And in death we sweetly slumber, When the King commands the spirit to be free, Never more with anguish laden We shall reach that lovely Aiden, When they ring the golden bells for you and me."
“当我们的日子数尽，当我们在死亡中甜蜜地沉睡，当国王命令灵魂自由，不再有苦难的负担，我们将到达那个可爱的艾登，当他们为你我敲响金钟时。”
Drive carefully.
小心驾驶。
Richard Lyons is in the band Negativland. His xeroxed book of crashed car photos and text isn't available anywhere. But the band is posting some of it on their website, if you're curious. The address of that website, www.negativland.com. And you spell Negativland, N-E-G-A-T-I-V-- no E there-- L-A-N-D.
理查德·里昂斯是Negativland乐队的成员。他的那本撞毁汽车照片和文字的影印书在任何地方都买不到。但如果你好奇的话，乐队正在他们的网站上发布其中的一些内容。该网站的地址是www.negativland.com。Negativland的拼写是N-E-G-A-T-I-V——没有E——L-A-N-D。
[MUSIC - "STEALING PEOPLE'S MAIL" BY DEAD KENNEDIES]
[音乐 - Dead Kennedies的《偷别人的信》]
Act Two, Thief. While there can be consequences to reading other people's mail, a friend of mine told me this story about his first job. In this job, he was a reporter at a small newspaper in a small town, and they had a basic office computer system. And then one day on a whim, he tried to log in as the owner of the newspaper. For the password, he just typed in the name of the guy's grandson. It worked. He suddenly had access to every file in the newspaper's computer, every story, every accounting record, every email.
第二幕，《小偷》。虽然读别人的信可能会有后果，但我的一位朋友告诉了我关于他第一份工作的故事。在那份工作中，他在一个小镇的一家小报社当记者，他们有一台基本的办公计算机系统。有一天一时兴起，他试着以报社老板的身份登录。密码，他直接输入了那家伙孙子的名字。居然成功了。他突然可以访问报社电脑里的每一个文件、每一篇报道、每一条会计记录、每一封电子邮件。
My friend says it was miserable. Most of the mail was depressingly banal, not worth reading. The main thing that he learned was that at the beginning of the year, nearly everyone in the office had gotten a bigger raise than he had. Reporters whose stories he thought were terrible had made much more than he did.
我的朋友说那很悲惨。大部分邮件都令人沮丧地平庸，不值得一读。他学到的主要事情是，在年初，办公室里几乎每个人都比他获得了更高的加薪。他认为报道写得很烂的记者赚的钱比他多得多。
When you open other people's mail, things can happen, unless you're careful. With that in mind, we turn to Mona Simpson. She's the author of numerous books. This is an excerpt of a short story she wrote a few years ago, called Lawns.
当你打开别人的信件时，事情可能会发生，除非你小心。考虑到这一点，我们转向莫娜·辛普森。她是许多书的作者。这是她几年前写的一篇短篇小说的节选，题目叫《草坪》。
I steal. I've stolen books and money and even letters. Letters are great. I work in the mail room of my dormitory, Saturday mornings. I sort mail, put the letters in these long narrow cubbyholes. The insides of mailboxes. It's cool there when I stick in my arm.
我偷窃。我偷过书、钱，甚至信件。信件很棒。我周六早上在宿舍的收发室工作。我整理邮件，把信件放进那些长而窄的小格子里。信箱的内侧。当我把手臂伸进去时，那里很凉快。
I've stolen cash-- these crisp, crackling, brand new twenty-dollar bills that fathers and grandmothers send, sealed up in sheets of wax paper. Once I got a fifty. I've stolen presents, too. I got a sweater and a football.
我偷过现金——那些父亲和祖母寄来的干脆、清脆、崭新的二十美元钞票，封在蜡纸里。有一次我拿到一张五十的。我也偷过礼物。我拿到过一件毛衣和一个橄榄球。
Mostly, what I take are cookies. No evidence. They're edible. I can spot the coffee cans of chocolate chip. You can smell it right through the wrapping. A cool smell, like the inside of a pantry. Sometimes I eat straight through the can during my shift.
大部分情况下，我拿的是饼干。没证据。它们是可以吃的。我能一眼认出那些巧克力碎咖啡罐。透过包装就能闻到。一种清凉的味道，就像储藏室里的味道。有时我在轮班期间直接把整罐吃掉。
Tampering with the United States mail is a Federal Crime, I know. Listen, let me tell you, I know. I got a summons in my mailbox to go to the Employment Office next Wednesday. Sure, I'm scared.
篡改美国邮件是一项联邦罪，我知道。听着，让我告诉你，我知道。我的信箱里收到了一张传票，让下周三去就业办公室。当然，我很害怕。
The University cops want to talk to me. Great. They think, suspect is the word they use, that one of us is throwing out mail instead of sorting it. Us is the others. I'm not the only sorter. I just work Saturdays, mail comes, you know, six days a week in this country. They'll never guess it's me.
大学警察想和我谈谈。太棒了。他们认为——“嫌疑”是他们用的词——我们中的一个人在扔掉邮件而不是整理它。“我们”是其他人。我不是唯一的整理员。我只是周六上班，你知道，这个国家的邮件每周发六天。他们永远不会猜到是我。
They say this in the letter, they think it's out of LAZINESS. Wanting to hurry up and get done, not spend the time. But I don't hurry. I'm really patient on Saturday mornings. I leave my dorm early, while Lauren's still asleep, I open the mailroom-- it's this heavy door and I have my own key.
他们在信中说，他们认为这是出于懒惰。想要快点干完，不想花时间。但我并不着急。周六早上我非常有耐心。我早早地离开宿舍，趁劳伦还在睡觉，我打开收发室——那是一扇沉重的门，我有自己的钥匙。
When I get there, two bags are already on the table, sagging, waiting for me. Two old ladies. One's packages, one's mail. There's a small key opens the bank of doors, the little boxes, from the inside. Through the glass part of every mail slot, I can see. The AstroTurf field across the street over the parking lot, it's this light green. I watch the sky go from black to gray to blue, while I'm there. Some days just stay foggy. Those are the best.
当我到达那里时，桌子上已经有两个袋子，耷拉着，等着我。两个老太太。一个是包裹，一个是邮件。有一把小钥匙可以从里面打开那一排门，那些小格子。透过每个投递口的玻璃部分，我可以看到。街对面停车场那边的草皮球场，是这种浅绿色。我在那里的时候，看着天空从黑色变成灰色再变成蓝色。有些日子天空一直有雾。那是最好的日子。
Once you open a letter, you can't just put it in the mailbox. The person's going to say something. So I stash them in my pack and throw them out. Just people I know. Susan Brown, I open. Andy Larsen, Larry Helprin. All the popular kids from my high school. These are kids who drove places together, took vacations. They all skied. They went to the prom in one big group. At morning nutrition-- nutrition, it's your break at 10 o'clock for doughnuts and stuff, California state law, you have to have it-- they used to meet outside on the far end of the math patio, all in one group. Some of them smoked. I've seen them look at each other, concerned, at 10:00 in the morning. One touched the inside of another's wrist, like grown-ups in trouble.
一旦你打开了一封信，你就不能只是把它放回信箱。那个人会说些什么的。所以我把它们藏在背包里然后扔掉。只是我认识的人。苏珊·布朗，我打开。安迪·拉尔森，拉里·赫尔普林。我高中的所有热门孩子。这些孩子一起开车去各地，去度假。他们都滑雪。他们一群人去参加舞会。在上午营养餐时间——营养餐，这是你上午10点吃甜甜圈之类的休息时间，加州法律规定，必须有——他们过去常在数学庭院尽头集合，全都在一群。他们中有些人抽烟。我见过他们在早上10点看着对方，神情担忧。一个人触碰另一个人的手腕内侧，就像遇到了麻烦的成年人。
And now I know, everything I thought those three years, worst years of my life, turns out to be true. The ones here get letters. Carrie's at Santa Cruz. Lily's in San Diego. Kevin's at Harvard. Beth's at Stanford. And like from families, their letters talk about problems. They're each other's main lives. You always knew looking at them in high school, they weren't just kids who had fun. They cared. They cared about things. They're all worried about Lily now. Larry and Annie are flying down to talk her into staying at school.
现在我知道了，我在那三年里想的一切，我一生中最糟糕的三年，原来都是真的。这里的人收到信。嘉莉在圣克鲁斯。莉莉在圣地亚哥。凯文在哈佛。贝丝在斯坦福。就像来自家庭的信件一样，它们谈论着问题。他们是彼此主要的生活。你在高中看他们时总是知道，他们不仅仅是玩得开心的孩子。他们在乎。他们在乎事情。他们现在都为莉莉担心。拉里和安妮正飞过去说服她留在学校。
I saw Glenn the day I came to Berkeley. I took a walk through campus and I'd been walking for almost an hour. And then I see Glenn coming down on a little hill by the infirmary, riding one of those lawn mowers you sit on, with grass flying out of the side. He's smiling. Not at me, just smiling. Clouds and sky behind his hair. Half of Tamalpais gone in fog. He was wearing this bright orange vest and I thought, fall's coming.
我到伯克利的当天就见到了格伦。我在校园里走了一圈，已经走了快一个小时了。然后我看到格伦骑着那种你可以坐在上面的割草机从医务室旁边的小山上下来，草从侧面飞出来。他在笑。不是对我笑，只是在笑。云和天空映在他头发后面。塔玛帕伊斯山的一半消失在雾中。他穿着这件亮橙色的背心，我想，秋天要来了。
I saw him that night again at our dorm cafeteria. This is the first time I've been in love. I worry. I'm a bad person, but Glenn's the perfect guy. I mean, for me at least. And he thinks he loves me. And I've got to keep him from finding out about me. I'll die before I'll tell him. Glenn. OK, Glenn. He looks like Mick Jagger, but sweet. 10 times sweeter. He looks like he's about 10 years old. His father's a doctor over at UC Med, gynecological surgeon.
那天晚上我在宿舍食堂又见到了他。这是我第一次坠入爱河。我很担心。我是个坏人，但格伦是个完美的人。我是说，至少对我来说。他以为他爱我。我必须让他发现不了我的秘密。我死也不会告诉他。格伦。好吧，格伦。他看起来像米克·贾格尔，但很甜。比那甜10倍。他看起来好像才10岁。他父亲是加州大学医学中心的一名医生，妇科外科医生。
First time we got together, a whole bunch of us were in Glenn's room, drinking beer. Glenn and his roommate collect beer cans. They have them stacked up. We're watching TV and finally everybody else leaves. There's nothing on but those gray lines and Glenn turns over on his bed and asks me if I'd rub his back. I couldn't believe this was happening to me. I knew I didn't have to do anything. I just had to stay there. It would happen. I was sitting on his rear end, rubbing his back, going under his shirt with my hands. All of a sudden I was worried about my breath and what I smelled like. Glenn's face was down in the pillow. I tried to sniff myself, but I couldn't tell anything. And it went all right anyway.
我们第一次聚在一起时，我们一大群人在格伦的房间里喝啤酒。格伦和他的室友收集啤酒罐。它们堆在一起。我们在看电视，最后大家都走了。电视上除了那些灰线什么都没有，格伦翻身躺在床上，问我能不能帮他揉揉背。我简直不敢相信这发生在我身上。我知道我什么都不用做。我只需要待在那里。它就会发生。我坐在他身后，揉着他的背，手伸进他的衬衫里。突然我开始担心我的呼吸和我的味道。格伦的脸埋在枕头里。我试图闻闻自己，但我什么也闻不出来。无论如何，一切都很顺利。
I don't open Glenn's letters, but I touch them. I hold them and smell them. None of his mail has any smell. He doesn't get many letters. His parents live across the Bay in Marin County. They don't write. He gets letters from his grandmother in Michigan, plain, even handwriting on regular envelopes, a sticker with her return address printed on it. Rural Route Number 3, Gunn Street. See, I got it memorized.
我不打开格伦的信，但我触摸它们。我拿着它们，闻着它们。他的邮件没有任何气味。他收到的信不多。他父母住在海湾对面的马林县。他们不写信。他收到密歇根州他祖母的信，普通的信封上写着平整的笔迹，贴着一张印有她回信地址的标签。乡村3号公路，冈恩街。你看，我把它背下来了。
And he gets letters from Diane. Di, they call her. High school girlfriend. Has a pushy mother, wants her to be a scientist, but she already got a C in Chem 1A. I got an A+, not to brag. He never slept with her, though. She wouldn't. She's still a virgin down in San Diego. With Lily, maybe they even know each other. Glenn and Di were popular kids in their high school, Redwood High. Now I'm one because of Glenn, because I'm his girlfriend. I know that's why. Not because of me. I just know, OK. I'm not going to start fooling myself now. Please.
他还收到黛安的信。他们叫她迪。高中女朋友。有一个爱管闲事的母亲，想让她成为科学家，但她在化学1A课上已经拿了C。我拿了A+，这不是吹牛。不过他从未和她睡过。她不肯。她在圣地亚哥还是个处女。和莉莉在一起，也许他们甚至认识。格伦和迪是他们高中红木高中的热门孩子。现在因为格伦，因为我是他的女朋友，我也成了一个热门人物。我知道那是原因。不是因为我。我只是知道，好吧。我现在不会开始自欺欺人了。拜托。
Her letters, I hold up to the light. They've got fluorescent lights in there. She's supposed to be blonde, you know, and pretty, quiet, the soft type. And the envelopes, she writes on these sheer cream-colored envelopes and they get transparent. And I can see her writing underneath, but not enough to read what it says. It's like those hockey lines painted under layers of ice. I run my tongue along the place where his grandmother sealed the letter. A sharp, sweet gummy taste. Once I cut my tongue.
她的信，我对着灯光看。那里有荧光灯。你知道，她应该是金发，漂亮，安静，那种温柔的类型。信封，她写在那种透明的乳白色信封上，它们变得透明了。我能看到她写在下面的字，但看不清写的是什么。就像涂在冰层下面的那些曲棍球线。我沿着他祖母封信的地方舔了一下。一种又尖又甜的口香糖味。有一次我割伤了舌头。
That's what keeps me going to the bottom of the bag. I'm always wondering if there will be a letter for Glenn. He doesn't get one every week. It's like a treasure, Crackerjack prize. But I'd never open Glenn's mail. I kiss all four corners where his fingers will touch, before I put it in his box.
这就是让我坚持到袋底的动力。我总是想知道是否会有格伦的信。他不是每周都有信。这就像一种宝藏，像Crackerjack奖品。但我绝不会打开格伦的信。在把它们放进他的信箱之前，我会亲吻他手指会触碰到的所有四个角。
I brought home cookies for Lauren and me. Just a present. We'll eat them or Glenn will eat them. I'll throw them out, for all I care. They're chocolate chip with pecans. This was one good mother, a lucky can. I brought us coffee, too. I bought it.
我给劳伦和我带了饼干回家。只是个礼物。我们吃或者格伦会吃。我不在乎，我会把它扔掉。那是带山核桃的巧克力碎饼干。这是一个好母亲，一个幸运的罐子。我也给我们买了咖啡。是我买的。
Yeah, OK, so I'm in trouble. Wednesday at 10:30 I got this notice I was supposed to appear. I had a class, Chem 1C, pre-med staple, your critical thing. I never missed it before. I told Glenn I had a doctor's appointment. OK, so I skip it anyway. And I walk into this room and there's these two other guys, all work in the mail room, doing what I do, sorting. And we all sit there on chairs, on this green carpet. I was staring at everybody's shoes.
是的，好吧，我惹麻烦了。周三10:30我收到了这张通知，要求我出面。我有一节课，化学1C，医学预科的基础课，你的关键课程。我以前从没缺席过。我告诉格伦我有个医生预约。好吧，所以我还是逃课了。我走进这个房间，还有另外两个家伙，都在收发室工作，做我做的事，整理邮件。我们都坐在椅子上，在绿色的地毯上。我一直盯着大家的鞋子。
And there's a cop, University cop, I don't know what's the difference. He had this sagging, pear-shaped body, like what my dad would have, if he were fat. But he's not. He's thin. He walks slowly on the carpeting, his fingers hooked in his belt loops. I was watching his hips. Anyway, he's accusing us all. And he's trying to get one of us to admit we did it. No way.
还有一个警察，大学警察，我不知道有什么区别。他有这种耷拉的、梨形的身体，如果我爸爸很胖的话，就像我爸爸那样。但他不胖。他很瘦。他在地毯上慢慢地走着，手指钩在皮带环里。我一直在看他的屁股。不管怎样，他在指责我们所有人。他想让我们其中一个人承认是我们做的。没门。
"I hope one of you will come to me and tell the truth. Not a one of you knows anything about this? Come on now."
“我希望你们中的一个人能来找我，说实话。你们中间难道一个都不知道吗？来吧。”
I shake my head no, and stare down at the three pairs of shoes. He says they're not going to do anything to the person who did it. Right. Want to make a bet? They say they just want to know. But they'll take it back, as soon as you tell them. I don't care why I don't believe him. I know one thing for sure, and that's they're not going to do anything to me, as long as I say no, I didn't do it. That's what I said, no, I didn't do it. I don't know a thing about it. I just can't imagine where those missing packages could have gone, how letters got into garbage cans, awful. I just don't know.
我摇摇头，盯着那三双鞋。他说他们不会对做这件事的人采取任何行动。对。想打赌吗？他们说他们只是想知道。但你一旦告诉他们，他们就会反悔。我不在乎我为什么不相信他。我肯定一件事，那就是他们不会对我采取任何行动，只要我坚持说不，我没做。那就是我说的，不，我没做。我对此一无所知。我简直无法想象那些丢失的包裹去了哪里，信件怎么会进了垃圾桶，太可怕了。我只是不知道。
This tall, skinny guy with a blonde mustache, Wallabees, looks kind of like a rabbit, he defended us. He's another sorter. Works Monday, Wednesdays. We all do our jobs, he says. None of us would do that. The rabbity guy looks at me and the other girl for support. So we're gonna stick together. The other girl, a dark blonde, chewing her lip, nodded. I loved that rabbity guy that second. I nodded, too. The cop looked down, wide hips, and the coffee-with-milk-colored pants. He sighed. I looked up at the rabbity guy. They let us all go.
这个长得瘦高、留着金胡子、穿Wallabees鞋、长得有点像兔子的家伙，他为我们辩护。他是另一个整理员。周一、周三上班。我们都做好我们的工作，他说。我们中没有一个人会做那种事。那个兔子的家伙看向我和另一个女孩寻求支持。所以我们要团结一致。另一个女孩，一个深金发，咬着嘴唇，点点头。那一秒我爱死了那个兔子的家伙。我也点了头。那个警察低头看着，宽大的臀部，穿着咖啡加奶颜色的裤子。他叹了口气。我看向那个兔子的家伙。他们放我们所有人走了。
I'm just going to keep saying no, not me, didn't do it. And I just won't do it again, that's all. Won't do it anymore. So this is Glenn's last chance for homemade cookies. I'm sure as hell not going to bake any. I signed the form, said I didn't do it. I'm OK now. I'm safe. It turned out OK after all. It always does. I always think something terrible is going to happen and it doesn't. I'm lucky.
我只会继续说不，不是我，没做。我再也不会那样做了，就这么简单。以后不会再做了。所以这是格伦收到自制饼干的最后机会。我肯定不会再烤了。我签了表格，说我没做。我现在没事了。我很安全。最后结果还是好的。总是这样。我总是觉得会有什么可怕的事情发生，但并没有。我很幸运。
I was walking just a little while ago today, down Telegraph with Glenn. And these two policemen, not the one I'd met, other policemen, were coming in our direction. I started sweating a lot. I was sure, until they passed us. I wish sure it was all over. They were there for me. I always think that. But at the same time, I know it's just my imagination. I mean, I'm a 4.0 student. I'm a nice girl, just walking down the street with my boyfriend.
不久前我今天还在走路，和格伦沿着电报街走。这两个警察，不是我见过的那个，其他警察，朝我们方向走来。我开始大量出汗。我确信，直到他们经过我们。我希望这一切都结束了。他们是冲我来的。我总是这么想。但同时，我知道这只是我的想象。我是说，我是个4.0的学生。我是个好女孩，只是和男朋友走在街上。
Novelist Mona Simpson, reading an excerpt from her story, Lawns. Coming up, postal employees reading your mail and bending the rules for you, yes, you. That's in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
小说家莫娜·辛普森，朗读她的小说《草坪》的节选。接下来，邮局员工阅读你的邮件并为你破例，没错，就是你。稍后，来自国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
Well, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we pick some theme, invite a wide variety of writers and performers and documentary producers to take a whack at that theme. Today's show, Other People's Mail, how it grabs your heart, whether you want it to or not.
好吧，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一些主题，邀请各种各样的作家、表演者和纪录片制作人来探讨这个主题。今天的节目，《别人的信》，讲述它如何抓住你的心，无论你是否愿意。
We have arrived at Act Three of our program, Saviors. If you work for the US Post Office, opening and reading other people's mail is actually one of the worst things you can do. You can be fired, investigated, imprisoned, unless you work at a Mail Recovery Center. There are three Mail Recovery Centers in the United States, in Atlanta, Sacramento, and St. Paul. Mail that cannot be delivered through any other means ends up there. There it is opened for a good cause, to look for clues to get it to you. Paul Tough visited these mail saviors in St. Paul.
我们来到了我们节目的第三幕，《救星》。如果你为美国邮政工作，拆开并阅读别人的邮件实际上是你能做的最糟糕的事情之一。你可能会被解雇、调查、监禁，除非你在邮件恢复中心工作。美国有三个邮件恢复中心，分别在亚特兰大、萨克拉门托和圣保罗。无法通过任何其他方式投递的邮件最终都会到达那里。在那里，它们为了一个崇高的目的而被打开，寻找线索将其送达给你。保罗·塔夫在圣保罗拜访了这些邮件救星。
There are a lot of reasons why things end up at the Mail Recovery Center. Someone left an address off a letter, someone moved and didn't let anybody know, someone's envelope got wet and then the ink ran. For whatever reason, it ends up here.
东西最终流落到邮件恢复中心的原因有很多。有人在信上没写地址，有人搬家了没告诉任何人，有人信封弄湿了然后墨水化了。无论什么原因，它最终会来到这里。
And a lot of it ends up here. There are 150,000 pieces of mail that arrive here each day. And the 75 people who work here all basically have the same job, to open up the mail, look inside, and see if they can figure out where it's supposed to go. And they see some pretty strange things, things that the rest of us don't. It's sort of a postal cross-section, a random sampling of what America mails. A clerk named Lauren [? Dicosad ?] told me about some of the things they find.
而且有很多东西最终流落到这里。每天有15万封邮件到达这里。而在这里工作的75个人基本上做的是同一份工作：打开邮件，往里面看，看看能不能弄清楚它该去哪里。他们看到了一些相当奇怪的东西，我们其他人没看到过的东西。这算是邮政的一个横截面，一个美国邮件的随机抽样。一位名叫劳伦·迪科萨德的职员告诉了我一些他们发现的事情。
Sometimes there will be mice, dead mice, naturally dead mice. Or bugs, they're sending it to somebody and telling them to bug off. And they'll throw in a real bug that used to be live. Things like that. When you're scanning, you just open it. And then you jump, because you don't know what it is. And then you'll dump it out and you'll find it. Dog poop, we hope it's dog poop. Cigarette butts, they'll empty their ashtrays into an envelope and send them to somebody.
有时会有老鼠，死老鼠，自然死亡的老鼠。或者虫子，他们把虫子寄给某人，让他们滚蛋。他们会扔进一只原本活着但现在死了的真正的虫子。类似这样的事情。当你扫描时，你只是打开它。然后你会被吓一跳，因为你不知道那是什么。然后你会把它倒出来，然后你会发现它。狗屎，我们希望是狗屎。烟蒂，他们会把烟灰缸里的东西清空到信封里寄给别人。
And that's in packages or in letters?
那是包裹里的还是信里的？
That's in letters. It's amazing. They'll put things in the letters that should never be there. Never, ever should be in a letter, but they'll put it in there. Tape it shut and throw it in the mailbox. And we end up with it.
那是信里的。太神奇了。他们会把那些本不该出现在那里的东西放进信里。永远，绝不应该出现在信里，但他们会把它放进去。用胶带封好扔进信箱。最后就到了我们手里。
The goal is always to return lost mail, if it's possible. Sometimes it's not too hard. There's a check in the envelope and there's an address on the check. They send it back. Sometimes the person's moved and left no forwarding address. In that case, there are clerks who scan through these huge computer databases of names and addresses. And sometimes they can find a good address that way. Sometimes they have to resort to real detective work, like Ken [? Grolkey, ?] who's been working here for eight years.
目标始终是尽可能退回丢失的邮件。有时这并不太难。信封里有一张支票，支票上有地址。他们就寄回去。有时那个人搬走了，没有留下转发地址。在这种情况下，有职员会浏览这些巨大的名字和地址电脑数据库。有时他们能通过这种方式找到一个正确的地址。有时他们必须诉诸真正的侦探工作，比如已经在那里工作了八年的肯·格罗尔基。
I came across a Christmas card and it had a bunch of photographs. And one of the photographs, there was a-- I know it was the person that had sent the letter. I could tell because she was showing off her house and her Christmas tree and her presents. And she was standing by the fireplace. And there's a whole bunch of her Christmas letters along the mantle there. So what I did was I took a magnifying glass and me and a friend were able to piece together her address from these five or six different Christmas cards that she had on her mantel piece. And a little bit of eye strain, but we couldn't get her name, but we got her address, her street address and her city and ZIP. Looked up the ZIP. Then we sent back her photographs. She probably never knew how we found that out. But I'm sure she got her photographs back.
我偶然发现了一张圣诞贺卡，里面有一堆照片。其中一张照片上，有一个——我知道那是寄信的人。我看得出来，因为她在炫耀她的房子、圣诞树和礼物。她站在壁炉边。壁炉架上有一堆她的圣诞信件。所以我做的是，我拿了一个放大镜，我和一个朋友设法从她壁炉架上的这五六张不同的圣诞贺卡中拼凑出了她的地址。眼睛有点累，但我们没能弄到她的名字，但我们得到了她的地址，她的街道地址、城市和邮编。查了邮编。然后我们退回了她的照片。她可能永远不知道我们是怎么发现的。但我确信她收回了她的照片。
Even with all these people making all this effort, only 10% of the packages and 30% of the letters that come into the Mail Recovery Center are successfully sent on. With some items, there's just no way to get them to their destination. There's no address, no return address, nothing at all. But then there are other items that maybe could be returned if you were willing to put the kind of effort into it that Ken [? Grolkey ?] did with the Christmas photos.
即使有这么多人付出这么多努力，进入邮件恢复中心的包裹中只有10%和信件中只有30%成功寄出。对于某些物品，确实没有办法将其送达目的地。没有地址，没有退信地址，什么都没有。但还有其他物品，如果你愿意付出像肯·格罗尔基处理圣诞照片那样的努力，也许是可以退回的。
The question is, is it worth it? And that's when the job gets tricky, deciding what's worth sending on and what's not. Greg Hawthorne is the acting supervisor on the day shift. He's management. He's not actually in there, dealing with the mail every day. And so, maybe a little predictably, when I ask him how you decide what gets sent back, he tells me that you go by the book.
问题是，这值得吗？这时工作就变得棘手了，决定什么值得寄出，什么不值得。格雷格·霍桑是白天的代理主管。他是管理层。他其实不在那儿，不是每天都在处理邮件。所以，也许有点可预见的是，当我问他如何决定退回什么时，他告诉我你要照章办事。
We have a-- it's called the Mail Recovery Manual. And I think it's 106. And all the regulations are in there. And we've had the same regulations for years and years and years. So somebody, somewhere down the road came up with these. And that's what we go by.
我们有一个手册——它叫《邮件恢复手册》。我想是106号。所有的规定都在里面。我们多年来一直沿用同样的规定。所以有人，在某个地方，想出了这些规定。我们就是照章办事的。
What that someone, somewhere decided was essentially what out of everything that we put in the mail is most valuable? Well, here's what the regulations say. Checks, they always get sent back. Legal papers, stock certificates, those get returned. With personal letters though, the basic rule is that if there's something worth $10 or more, that gets sent back, if it can. But everything else gets disposed of.
那个在某处的人基本上决定了我们在邮件中投递的所有东西中什么最有价值？好吧，这就是规定所说的。支票，它们总是被寄回。法律文件、股票证书，那些会被退回。不过个人信件，基本规则是如果有什么东西价值10美元或以上，如果可以的话，就寄回去。但其他一切都会被处理掉。
When we receive 150,000 letters a day, we don't have time to sit and read everything. So personal letters are basically shredded.
当我们每天收到15万封信时，我们没有时间坐下来阅读一切。所以个人信件基本上都被粉碎了。
That's Greg's version. But when I talk to the people who actually deal with the mail, I heard a different story. This is Anne [? Zeemer. ?]
那是格雷格的说法。但当我与真正处理邮件的人交谈时，我听到了不同的故事。这是安妮·齐默。
There are policies on what our limits are. But we make our own exceptions. If we see a piece of foreign mail, for instance, that looks important, a wedding invitation that would still be able to be returned in time, something like that, policy says no, don't return it. But probably, in my judgment anyway, I would return it. And most of those other girls feel the same way, too.
关于我们的限制是有政策的。但我们也会破例。例如，如果我们看到一封看起来很重要的外国邮件，比如一封本可以及时退回的婚礼请柬之类的，政策说不，不要退回。但可能，至少在我的判断中，我会退回它。其他大多数女孩也觉得一样。
The reason for this difference of opinion is pretty simple. It's not that Greg is a by-the-book square and Anne is a rule-bending softie. It's not that Greg is management and Anne is labor. It's that Greg doesn't read other people's mail all day. And Anne, and Ken, and Lorinda, and all the other clerks I spoke to in St. Paul, they do. And that changes things. They're face to face every day with parts of our lives whose value is hard to quantify.
这种意见分歧的原因很简单。并不是说格雷格是个照章办事的死板人，安妮是个违规的烂好人。并不是说格雷格是管理层，安妮是劳工。而是格雷格不会整天阅读别人的邮件。而安妮、肯、劳琳达，以及我在圣保罗交谈过的所有其他职员，他们读。这改变了事情。他们每天都面对面地接触着我们生活中那些价值难以量化的部分。
What is important to one human being is maybe not important to another, but these people that are sending--
对一个人来说重要的东西，对另一个人来说可能不重要，但这些人正在寄出的——
This is Betty Jones.
这是贝蒂·琼斯。
And I'll give an example. And this is something that I do, which probably not a lot of people do. For example, people send little angels through the mail. And it's a real positive thing that they're saying to someone who is in real bad-- having a really bad life or they're very depressed or they're on the verge of suicide. And you kind of scan it and see that there wasn't maybe enough postage on it, there wasn't enough whatever. I send it forward to the person that they're trying to send it to.
我会举个例子。这是我做的事情，可能没多少人做。例如，人们通过邮件寄送小天使。这是他们对处于非常糟糕的生活中、非常沮丧或处于自杀边缘的人所说的非常积极的话。你会扫描一下，看到可能邮资不足，或者什么原因。我把它转发给他们试图寄给的那个人。
And it may seem unimportant to someone else. And perhaps the postal service wouldn't think it was maybe important, but I feel it is. And I feel it's within our realm to make that judgment.
这对其他人来说可能看起来不重要。也许邮政服务不会认为这很重要，但我认为很重要。我觉得在我们这个范围内做出这种判断。
The clerks here say it's a strange experience to see into all of these lives. Strange, and not always happy. One day after work, Betty and I sat out behind the Mail Recovery Center, at a picnic table next to the loading docks. And we spoke for awhile about what that experience is like.
这里的职员说，深入了解所有这些生活是一种奇怪的经历。奇怪，而且并不总是快乐。下班后的一天，贝蒂和我在邮件恢复中心后面的一张野餐桌旁，就在装卸码头旁边。我们谈了一会儿那种经历是什么样的。
You see a lot that's going on, just like you see in the news. And you think oh, I see that in the news. I see that at work all the time. This goes on or that goes on. These people's lives change. And we see it in the letters that we have to scan.
你看到了很多正在发生的事情，就像你在新闻里看到的一样。你会想哦，我在新闻里见过那个。我每天在工作中都看到那个。这发生或者那发生。这些人的生活变了。我们在必须扫描的信件中看到了它。
Betty actually had to fight with the post office in order to keep her job at the Mail Recovery Center. She first came here in 1989, on a temporary basis after she developed carpal tunnel syndrome at her previous job sorting mail. But after five years, she was told that she couldn't work here anymore. They said that because of her injuries, she wasn't able to do the job. And that was despite the fact that she'd been doing it successfully for years.
贝蒂其实不得不与邮局抗争才能保住她在邮件恢复中心的工作。她是在1989年首次来到这里的，当时她在之前整理邮件的工作中患上了腕管综合征，后来以临时身份来到这里。但五年后，她被告知她不能再在这里工作了。他们说因为她的伤，她不能做这份工作。尽管事实上她已经成功地做了好几年。
She filed a grievance. And after a few months in limbo, she won her job back. And of all the people I talked to here, she's the one who seems to be the most affected by what she sees in the mail. I don't know if it's because of everything that she had to go through to stay here, but I think it might be.
她提出了申诉。在经历了几个月的悬而未决后，她赢回了她的工作。在我在这里交谈过的所有人中，她似乎是受邮件内容影响最深的一个。我不知道这是不是因为她为了留在这里所经历的一切，但我认为可能是。
It bothers me to see a lot of people that are in so much pain and problems and they're sending these sad letters to someone and it doesn't get to them. I've seen a couple letters that were like long lost loves, trying to contact each other. And it was sad when you couldn't find an address to send it on to or back to.
看到这么多陷入如此多痛苦和问题的人，他们给别人寄这些悲伤的信却送不到，这让我很困扰。我见过几封信，就像久别重逢的爱人，试图联系对方。当你找不到地址寄出或退回时，那是很悲伤的。
And then there are people in the world that are very needy. They have very little in their life. And you feel like you wish you could reach out and take all the names of all these people, which we're not allowed to do, and write down the names and addresses and go out and try to help them out. Just take up a collection for them or something.
世界上还有非常贫困的人。他们生活中拥有的很少。你会觉得你希望你能伸出援手，把所有这些人的名字都记下来——我们是不允许这样做的——写下名字和地址，然后走出去，试着帮助他们。给他们募捐什么的。
I should say at this point that all of the clerks I spoke to, especially Betty, emphasized that they're not just diving into a pile of mail and reading through people's personal letters for curiosity's sake. They open first-class mail to look for items of value, things that are worth more than $10, like maybe some cash or a pin or some photos. And then they scan the letters. They don't read them, everyone told me. They scan them, looking for an address or a name or any information that might help get the letter to where it's supposed to go.
我应该在这一点上说，所有我交谈过的职员，尤其是贝蒂，都强调他们不是为了好奇而一头扎进一堆邮件中去阅读人们的个人信件。他们打开一等邮件是为了寻找有价值的东西，那些价值超过10美元的东西，比如一些现金、一枚胸针或一些照片。然后他们扫描信件。每个人都告诉我，他们不阅读它们。他们扫描它们，寻找地址或名字，或者任何可能有助于将信件送达目的地的潜在信息。
I believe everyone who told me this. I don't think anyone at the Mail Recovery Center reads mail for any kind of voyeuristic thrill. But I also believe that, like everything at the Center, the reality is more complicated than the regulations. And when you've just opened a letter from a child to her mother who's in prison, or from a man writing to his dead wife, the human material in front of you is so incredible that you can't help but scan a little more slowly than is perhaps absolutely necessary.
我相信所有告诉我这些的人。我不认为邮件恢复中心的任何人会为了某种偷窥的快感而阅读邮件。但我也相信，就像中心的一切一样，现实比规定更复杂。当你刚刚打开一封从孩子寄给在监狱里的母亲的信，或者从一个男人写给已故妻子的信时，你面前的人类素材是如此令人难以置信，以至于你忍不住扫描得比绝对必要的时间稍微慢一点。
Someone telling someone, it's over, I don't care for you anymore-- or gee, so-and-so died, or so-and-so got killed last year, or your daughter is dying of cancer. People writing-- oh, they'll have maybe a birth certificate or something inside. And they're writing to someone, here's your daughter's birth certificate. You can take care of the kids. I'm leaving. Or people breaking engagements--
有人告诉某人，结束了，我不再关心你了——或者天哪，某某死了，或者某某去年被杀了，或者你的女儿正死于癌症。人们写——哦，他们里面可能有一张出生证明之类的东西。他们正在写给某人，这是你女儿的出生证明。你可以照顾孩子。我走了。或者人们解除婚约——
That feeling of personal connection that the clerks get from reading other people's mail is sometimes painful. But it's also precisely what makes mail recovery one of the most sought-after jobs in the post office. I didn't quite realize how sought-after a job it is, though, until I spoke one morning to Jerry Jacobson. He doesn't work at the Mail Recovery Center. He works for the union in Saint Paul that represents these workers. But before he got his union job, he spent 12 years working as a postal clerk, sorting letters. And he told me that about half the people who work in the post office work out of sight of the public, in warehouses, where they operate the giant machines that sort the nation's mail.
职员从阅读别人的邮件中获得的这种个人联系感有时是痛苦的。但这恰恰使邮件恢复成为邮局最受欢迎的工作之一。不过，直到有一天早上我与杰里·雅各布森交谈时，我才真正意识到这份工作有多受欢迎。他不在邮件恢复中心工作。他在圣保罗代表这些工人的工会工作。但在他获得工会工作之前，他做了12年的邮政职员，整理信件。他告诉我，大约一半在邮局工作的人是在公众视野之外工作的，在仓库里，在那里他们操作分拣国家邮件的巨大机器。
On the machine that we worked at, they would call them LSMs or MPLSMs, multi-position letter sorting machine. There's actually like 12 consoles. And it would take a crew of about 18 people to run it or operate it.
在我们工作的机器上，他们称之为LSM或MPLSM，多位置信件分拣机。其实有12个控制台。操作它需要大约18人的团队。
People would be sitting at all 12 consoles. We had a couple of people that were loading. And then people that were on the back side of the machine that would sweep the mail. We had to learn to see a letter that was on the machine, on the console. And it would drop the mail into a slot, basically right in front of us, one at a time. And it would stop in front of us. We had 4/10 of a second to look at the mail, read the ZIP code or the address, decide where it was to go, and then the mail would take off. And as it was going into the machine, we had 6/10 of a second to key a series of buttons as far as a code or sequence for it. And then that was, of course, computerized. So it would go into the machine and the machine would drop it in a specific bin on the back side.
人们会坐在所有12个控制台上。我们有几个人在负责装载。然后是机器背面负责清扫邮件的人。我们必须学会识别机器上控制台上的信件。信件会一个接一个地掉进我们面前的槽里。它会停在我们面前。我们有0.4秒的时间看邮件，读邮编或地址，决定去哪里，然后邮件就会走。当它进入机器时，我们有0.6秒的时间键入一系列按钮，作为它的代码或顺序。然后当然是电脑化的。所以它会进入机器，机器会把它掉进背面特定的槽里。
Almost everyone I interviewed that worked at the Mail Recovery Center had spent at least a few years on a letter sorting machine, punching in 60 codes a minute, eight hours a day. Ken did it. Lorinda did it. Betty did it. That's how she got carpal tunnel syndrome. No one I talked to looked back on those years with much fondness.
我采访过的在邮件恢复中心工作的几乎每个人，都曾在信件分拣机上工作过至少几年，每天工作八小时，每分钟敲入60个代码。肯做过。劳琳达做过。贝蒂做过。这就是她患上腕管综合征的原因。我交谈过的没有一个人带着多少留恋回顾那些岁月。
But the people who work at the St. Paul Mail Recovery Center may, in fact, soon have to go back to the mail sorting jobs that they escaped. When I visited, everybody was talking about this proposal that had just been floated that would shut the Center down in just a few months. No one's sure now whether it's really going to happen. Information's hard to come by, even for people that work there. But next October, the post office's board of governors is going to meet to discuss the Center's future. And they might decide to shut it down for good.
但圣保罗邮件恢复中心的人可能很快就会回到他们逃离的邮件分拣工作中。我访问时，每个人都在谈论刚刚提出的一个提案，该提案将在几个月内关闭该中心。现在没人确定这是否真的会发生。即使对在那里工作的人来说，信息也很难获得。但明年十月，邮局的董事会将开会讨论该中心的未来。他们可能会决定永远关闭它。
A lot of the people I spoke to in St. Paul saw this as a symptom of larger changes that are going on in the post office. A few years ago, there were seven Mail Recovery Centers around the country. Now there are three. And there's talk of closing another one soon. The reason is that the people in charge of the post office have, over the past few years, been concentrating more and more on cost cutting, and that means automation. Every part of the post office, from letter sorting to delivery, and even to mail recovery, is becoming more automated. The result is that postal workers, the ones I spoke to anyway, feel less and less valuable to the people in charge.
我在圣保罗交谈过的许多人都认为这是邮局正在发生的大规模变化的症状。几年前，全国有七个邮件恢复中心。现在有三个。而且有传言说很快要再关闭一个。原因是邮局的负责人过去几年越来越集中于削减成本，这意味着自动化。邮局的每个部分，从信件分拣到投递，甚至到邮件恢复，都在变得更加自动化。结果是邮政工人们——至少我交谈过的那些——觉得自己对负责人的价值越来越低。
I think it was you, Betty, who said that if the people at the top really knew what was going on in here, knew what sort of work people were doing in here, they wouldn't be trying to close it. What is it that they don't know?
我想是你，贝蒂，你说过，如果上面的人真的知道这里在发生什么，知道人们在这里做的是什么样的工作，他们就不会试图关闭它。他们不知道的是什么？
They're in Washington. And they're far away from this facility. Some of them have never worked on a workroom floor. These people that are in charge of-- the Postmaster General, I don't believe, has ever been a postal employee. So they don't have any concept of what goes on in the system. The sad part is even if those people came here physically, they just-- I hate to say it, my opinion-- I don't think they would care. And that is sad for the customer and it's sad for the employee, because you take pride in your work and you want to do what's right for the customer. And these people are making decisions that are so illogical.
他们在华盛顿。他们离这个设施很远。他们有些人从没在工作现场工作过。这些负责人——邮政局长，我相信，从来没有当过邮政员工。所以他们对系统中发生的事情没有任何概念。可悲的是，即使这些人亲自来到这里，他们只是——我不愿说，我的看法——我不认为他们会在意。这对客户来说很可悲，对员工来说也很可悲，因为你为你的工作感到自豪，你想要为客户做正确的事。而这些人做出的决定太不合逻辑了。
The great thing about the Mail Recovery Center is this, you've got this vast machine called the United States Postal Service, which is becoming more and more automated, less and less human. And then here in this little out-of-the-way warehouse on an access road in St. Paul, you've got 75 people who are doing work that takes brains and heart, that makes them fulfilled, and makes the people they serve happy. It's like the land that time forgot.
邮件恢复中心伟大的地方在于此：你拥有这个被称为美国邮政服务的巨大机器，它变得越来越自动化，越来越没有人情味。然后在这里，在圣保罗一条通道上的这个不起眼的小仓库里，你有75个人在做需要大脑和心智的工作，这让他们感到充实，并让被他们服务的人感到高兴。这就像被时间遗忘的土地。
One of the weird things about talking to the people at the MRC about the possibility that they might lose their jobs, was that they were upset about it. But they also seem kind of resigned to it. It's like they knew that they were out of step with the new go-go, super-automated post office. It's like they felt that they've been getting away with something by having interesting jobs, and now they've been found out.
与MRC的人谈论他们可能失去工作的可能性时，奇怪的事情之一是，他们对此感到不安。但他们似乎也对此感到认命。就像他们知道自己与新的、超级自动化的邮局格格不入。就像他们觉得因为有有趣的工作而占了便宜，而现在被发现了。
On the wall of the Mail Recovery Center are posted a slew of letters, mostly handwritten, from people who have had things returned to them. All the letters are filled with gratitude. And what's more, they all have this air of amazement to them. None of these people knew that this service even existed. And then suddenly, they got their insurance forms or their bank deposits or their engagement ring back. One letter that Greg Hawthorne showed me said, "We want to let you know how much we appreciate you taking the time to find our Christmas gifts. You've restored our faith in humanity." You have to wonder if 10 years from now, the post office will still be getting letters like that.
邮件恢复中心的墙上贴着一大堆信件，大部分是手写的，来自收到失物退回的人们。所有的信都充满了感激之情。而且更重要的是，它们都带着一种惊奇感。这些人根本不知道这种服务甚至存在。然后突然之间，他们收回了保险单、银行存款或订婚戒指。格雷格·霍桑给我看的一封信说：“我们想让你知道，我们有多感激你花时间寻找我们的圣诞礼物。你恢复了我们对人类的信仰。”你不得不怀疑10年后，邮局是否还会收到这样的信。
[MUSIC - "THE LETTER" BY MEKONS]
[音乐 - Mekons的《信》]
Act Four, Golden Rule.
第四幕，《黄金法则》。
Hold it right there, buddy. There is something indecent about the entire premise of this week's show.
就在那儿停下，哥们。这个节目本周的整个前提都有点不体面。
This is Sarah Vowell, a contributing editor to This American Life.
这是莎拉·沃威尔，《美国生活》的特约编辑。
The title says it all, Other People's Mail. There's an apostrophe stuck on to that word, people. Now, I know that it's small and you could miss it pretty easily. But there's a world of meaning packed into that teensy little mark. It connotes the possessive case. And maybe I'm being too literal, but the apostrophe draws a line between your stuff and someone else's.
标题说明了一切，《别人的信》。在“人”这个词后面有一个撇号。现在，我知道它很小，你很容易错过。但在那个小小的符号里包含着一个世界的意义。它暗示了所有格。也许我太死板了，但这个撇号划清了你的东西和别人的东西之间的界限。
Alternative titles I've considered for this, the Other People's Mail show, are None Of Your Bee's Wax, or I Got One Word For You, Gestapo, or Hey You, Get Out Of My Trash. I don't mean to sound self-righteous. Sure, what human being can resist reading over her neighbor's shoulder in the subway or looking in someone's window, if it's all lit up. But I'd like to think that in a democracy, in This American Life , Mr. Glass, the words personal and private still mean something.
我已经考虑过这个《别人的信》节目的替代标题，比如《不关你的事》，或者《我有一个词送给你，盖世太保》，或者《嘿你，从我的垃圾里滚出去》。我不是想显得自命不凡。当然，谁能抵挡在地铁上偷看邻居的肩膀，或者如果窗户亮着的时候往里面看。但我愿意认为，在一个民主国家，在《美国生活》中，格拉斯先生，个人和隐私这两个词仍然意味着什么。
Still, I have a job to do. And my job is not to prejudge, but to evaluate fair and square. So I went to Boston, as assigned, to visit Phil Milstein. He works as a graphic designer and lives in a normal apartment, filled with an abnormal number of shelves. He's a serious collector of other people's stuff, not just their mail-- crumpled notes he finds on the street, pieces of gum chewed by minor celebrities, and grocery shopping lists, which he scoops off the supermarket floor and pastes into scrapbooks.
尽管如此，我还有工作要做。我的工作不是先入为主，而是公平地评估。所以我按指定去了波士顿，去拜访菲尔·米尔斯坦。他是一名平面设计师，住在一间普通的公寓里，摆满了数量异常多的架子。他是一个热衷于收集别人东西的收藏家，不仅是邮件——他在街上找到的揉皱的便条，小名人们嚼过的口香糖，还有杂货购物清单，他从超市地板上捡起来贴进剪贴簿里。
Here is one of my very favorites, a typed shopping list. And best yet, they have cheese twice in a row. They really want cheese-- garbage bags, beans, cheese, cheese, lysol, rug cleaner, sponge, and bread.
这是我最喜欢的一张，一张打印的购物清单。最好的是，他们连续两次要奶酪。他们真的很想要奶酪——垃圾袋、豆子、奶酪、奶酪、来苏尔、地毯清洁剂、海绵和面包。
And they forgot to capitalize Lysol, because that is a proper name.
而且他们忘了把Lysol的首字母大写，因为那是一个专有名词。
But they don't capitalize anything. So maybe they just were too lazy to hit the caps lock key on there. It's a manual typewriter, you'll notice. And so I can forgive them, not bothering with the caps-- those caps locks are heavy on those manuals.
但他们什么都不大写。所以也许他们只是太懒了，没去按那个大写锁定键。这是一个手动打字机，你会注意到的。所以我可以原谅他们，不为大写烦恼——那些大写锁定键在手动打字机上很重。
As voyeurism goes, the shopping lists are harmless. All Phil is doing is trying to catch a glimpse of another human being in the most mundane series of nouns.
作为偷窥，购物清单是无害的。菲尔所做的只是试图通过最平凡的一系列名词来一窥另一个人。
There is an element of strangeness that this reveals. I think that you're really getting down into a person's real inner psyche when they draw up a shopping list. I mean there's something very raw about the way people write these things. And that's part of what I'm after.
这揭示了一种陌生感。我认为当你起草购物清单时，你真的深入到了一个人的真实内心世界。我是说，人们写这些东西的方式有非常原始的东西。这就是我所追求的一部分。
Phil also collects those little pieces of paper you doodle on in art supply stores to try out the pens. And he claims that they, too, tell him something about the inner life of random strangers. But this collection is altogether more magical. Even though these scribblings were created by people trying to decide between BIC or Pilot Precise, they're done in very striking colors. And many of them look like fairly acceptable abstract art.
菲尔还收集了那些你在美术用品店涂鸦以试用钢笔的小纸片。他声称，它们也告诉了他关于随机陌生人内心生活的一些事情。但这个收藏更有魔力。尽管这些涂鸦是人们在BIC或Pilot Precise之间犹豫不决时创造的，但它们是用非常引人注目的颜色完成的。而且许多看起来像相当可以接受的抽象艺术。
Some of them really do kind of reveal a person's subconscious, because when you're just testing the marker you're not really thinking about what you're writing. And so perhaps some truth might emerge that you're not really in control of. This person made some nice drawings of pirates or something using different colored pens and some markers. They're very colorful. And I think they're really pretty just to look at. This person drew a lot of music notes.
其中一些真的揭示了一个人的潜意识，因为当你只是在测试马克笔时，你并没有真正思考你在写什么。所以也许一些你无法控制的真相可能会浮现出来。这个人画了一些漂亮的海盗或什么的，使用了不同颜色的钢笔和一些马克笔。它们非常丰富多彩。而且我认为它们真的很漂亮。这个人画了很多音符。
We're kind of skating on the edge of something that some people devote their professional lives to. And I'm flipping through this book. I mean, especially the abstract-- like you said the abstract ones are kind of the most beautiful. And flipping through, I think oh, there's Kandinsky, and there's Cy Twombly, and there is Jackson Pollock, and there is Helen Frankenthaler, or whatever. But it's not-- I mean, how has looking at these changed the way that you look at real art?
我们有点滑向某些人将其作为毕生事业的东西的边缘。我在翻这本书。我是说，尤其是抽象的——就像你说的，抽象的是最美丽的。翻看着，我想哦，那是康定斯基，那是赛·托姆布雷，那是杰克逊·波洛克，那是海伦·弗兰肯萨勒，什么的。但它不是——我是说，看着这些东西怎么改变了你看待真正艺术的方式？
I'm not sure that I do look at real art. I mean, I'm a sucker for these clashing, garish colors. Like hypnotizing a chicken, it's just not that hard to get art that appeals to me. Just put a lot of nice colors in and I'll be there.
我不确定我是不是在看真正的艺术。我是说，我喜欢这些冲突、刺眼的颜色。就像催眠一只鸡，想要那种吸引我的艺术并不难。只要放进很多漂亮的颜色，我就在那里。
If I could, I'd like to just get a plug in here for Western civilization as we know it. I've always been more interested in the things you need card catalogs to find than the stuff you just come across willy-nilly on the street. I like James Baldwin and Pablo Picasso and Sonic Youth.
如果可以的话，我想在这里为我们所知的西方文明代言。我一直对那些需要卡片目录才能找到的东西比那些你在街上随意捡到的东西更感兴趣。我喜欢詹姆斯·鲍德温、巴勃罗·毕加索和音速青年。
Is that it with you? I mean do you really think you just have low standards? I mean, what do you see as the common theme of the things you collect?
你就是这样吗？你是真的认为你只是标准低吗？我是说，你认为你收集的东西的共同主题是什么？
I think what interests me-- and this is almost in direct contrast to classical literature and art that you refer to-- I enjoy the snapshot of a moment of an average person's real life. I find it more interesting and more revealing than classical art or self-conscious art, art created as art. It's hard. You have to really think. And I just find the average person's work more interesting. Maybe it's a matter of, as a person of limited ability myself, I relate to that more.
我认为让我感兴趣的是——这几乎与你提到的古典文学和艺术形成了直接对比——我喜欢普通人真实生活片段的快照。我发现它比古典艺术或自我意识的艺术，即作为艺术而创造的艺术，更有趣，更具启发性。这很难。你必须真正思考。我只是觉得普通人的作品更有趣。也许这是一个问题，作为一个能力有限的人，我对此有更多的共鸣。
What bothers you about excellence?
卓越之处有什么让你感到困扰？
It's intimidating. I can't relate to it. It's beyond my abilities. And it makes me-- because deep down I want to be able to do great things, but I've never really been able to. So there is an unfulfilled desire that I'm forced to confront every time I see something great. In myself I just say, wow, that's above anything I could ever do. And it makes me realize all over again my own ordinariness.
这令人望而生畏。我无法产生共鸣。这超出了我的能力。这让我——因为在内心深处，我想能够做伟大的事情，但我从来没有真正做到过。所以每次我看到伟大的东西时，我都被迫面对一个未实现的愿望。在自己身上，我只是说，哇，那高于我能做的任何事情。这让我再次意识到我自己的平庸。
But, I mean, we're sitting in this room next to your record collection, and I'm looking at it, and I'm like, there are the Stooges, who I think are great. There's Little Richard, whom some days is my favorite singer. I mean, this room is wall-to-wall greatness.
但是，我是说，我们正坐在你唱片收藏旁边的房间里，我看着它，我想，那是斯图奇乐队，我认为他们很伟大。那是小理查德，有时是我最喜欢的歌手。我是说，这个房间全是墙到墙的伟大。
Yeah. But a lot of that comes from the period of my life where I was striving for that myself. And much of the more recent acquisitions is from the period in my life where I resigned myself to never being great, and switched my interests instead to documenting the abilities of everyday people.
是的。但这很多来自于我人生中追求伟大的那个时期。而最近大部分的收获来自于我人生中辞职不再追求伟大，转而把兴趣转向记录普通人能力的时期。
[MUSIC - "ELVIS" BY PAULINE D. WASSILCHAK]
[音乐 - Pauline D. Wassilchak的《猫王》]
These are the kinds of records Phil listens to these days. They're called song poems. They're written by amateurs who answered ads in magazines asking for song lyrics, and studio hacks set their words to music for a fee. Phil doesn't just collect them. He's compiled four CDs of them and is writing a book about the phenomenon.
这些就是菲尔最近听的唱片。它们叫歌曲诗。它们是由业余爱好者写的，他们回答了杂志上征集歌词的广告，录音室黑客付钱将他们的文字配上音乐。菲尔不仅收集它们。他还整理了四张CD，并正在写一本关于这种现象的书。
This particular one is called "Elvis," by someone named Pauleen D. Wassilchak. And while it has its charms, I don't think Iggy Popp has anything to worry about.
这一首特别的叫《猫王》，由一个叫宝琳·D·瓦西查克的人创作。虽然它有它的魅力，但我不认为伊基·波普有什么好担心的。
[MUSIC - "ELVIS" BY PAULINE D. WASSILCHAK]
[音乐 - Pauline D. Wassilchak的《猫王》]
Phil's most morally questionable collection is the bag full of a college student's love letters to her boyfriend. Not only has Phil read her letters, he's published them in a zine called Rollerderby , and put them up on the World Wide Web. Most of the letters are pretty saccharin, beyond banal. Many of them are written on cutesy, teddy-bear greeting cards. And no, because of that apostrophe I mentioned earlier, you won't be hearing this woman's secret thoughts on the air. This is a private correspondence. And even Phil can't justify his claims on it.
菲尔最在道德上有疑问的收藏是一袋大学生的情书，写给她的男朋友。菲尔不仅读了她的信，还在一本叫《Rollerderby》的杂志上发表了它们，并把它们放到了万维网上。大部分信件都非常甜腻，平庸得要命。其中许多是写在可爱的泰迪熊贺卡上的。而且不，因为我之前提到的那个撇号，你不会在广播里听到这个女人的秘密想法。这是一份私人通信。即使菲尔也无法证明他对它的权利。
Ethically, this makes me scum. She certainly comes across as vapid. And inane as she comes across-- ethically, morally, she's clearly superior. She's trying hard to be a decent person. And you get that sense through her letters. And I, in a sense, am a total scumbag for picking apart her private life and making fun of it.
从道德上讲，这让我成了渣滓。她给人的印象当然是浅薄。无论她表现得多么愚蠢——在道德上，她显然更优越。她努力想做一个体面的人。你通过她的信件感受到了这一点。而在某种意义上，我是一个彻头彻尾的渣滓，去拆解她的私人生活并拿它取乐。
It was at this moment that I noticed that all the shades in Phil's apartment were drawn. He doesn't want other people, people like him, to look in. I tried to make light of it. But every time I asked him a question as a joke, he responded point-blank, for real. Yes, he has binoculars. Yes, he uses them to peep into windows. Yes, he'd watch you having sex and better yet, getting killed. And yes, he's seen Rear Window , six times.
就在那一刻，我注意到菲尔公寓里所有的遮阳帘都拉着。他不希望其他人，像他那样的人，往里看。我试图把它轻描淡写。但每次我开玩笑地问他一个问题时，他都会直截了当地回答，来真的。是的，他有双筒望远镜。是的，他用它们窥视窗户。是的，他会看着你做爱，更好的是，看着你被杀。是的，他看过《后窗》，六次。
And no, he doesn't want other people, people like him, to read his mail. So he's considering buying a paper shredder. They're coming down in price, you know.
而且不，他不希望其他人，像他那样的人，读他的信。所以他正在考虑买一台碎纸机。它们的价格正在下降，你知道。
Every time I go into the office supply store, I look at the shredders. And when they get cheap enough, I probably will get one because I do have personal things that I throw out. And I hope no one ever does to me what I do to them.
每次我去办公用品店，我都会看碎纸机。当它们便宜到一定程度时，我可能会买一个，因为我确实有一些我会扔掉的个人物品。我希望没有人会对我做我对他做的事。
Sarah Vowell enforces her moral vision of the world as a columnist in the online magazine Salon , and here on This American Life. Well, our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself, with Paul Tough, Alix Spiegel, and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors Sarah Vowell, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin. Our current staff includes Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton, Blue Chevigny, Starlee Kine, and Todd Bachmann.
莎拉·沃威尔以在线杂志《沙龙》的专栏作家的身份以及在这里的《美国生活》中推行她对世界的道德观。好吧，我们的节目今天由朱莉·斯奈德和我制作，保罗·塔夫、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克参与。特约编辑莎拉·沃威尔、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。我们当前的工作人员包括亚历克斯·布隆伯格、苏珊·伯顿、蓝色切维尼、斯塔莉·凯恩和托德·巴赫曼。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
To buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you know you can listen to most of our programs for free, absolutely free, on the internet at our website, where you can also find all sorts of stuff that we don't put onto the radio show, www.thislife.org. Thanks Elizabeth Meister, who runs the site. This American Life distributed by Public Radio International.
购买此节目的录音带，请致电芝加哥WBEZ，电话312-832-3380。或者你知道你可以在互联网上的我们的网站上免费、完全免费地收听我们的大部分节目，在那里你还可以找到我们没有放入广播节目的各种东西，www.thislife.org。感谢运行该网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who insists--
WBEZ管理监督托里·马拉蒂亚，他坚持——
I don't have any more pimples. And I am not that white.
我没有更多的粉刺了。而且我也没有那么苍白。
I'm IRA Glass. Back next week, with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。